on either side of the border are two
villages that were built as symbols of
peace but stand as reminders of country
still technically at war here in the
middle of the Demilitarized Zone a line
of trees is all that separates North and
South Korea de song dong is the only
civilian South Korean settlement inside
the buffer zone which was created when
the Korean War ended with an armistice
in 1953 we live so close by and we see
the soldiers all the time we can feel
any change of atmosphere directly as we
live with the soldiers and the North
Koreans right across from us access to
this isolated village of less than 200
people is strictly controlled by
soldiers under the United Nations
commands it's a unique place in many
ways and now has something most of the
world doesn't a 5g cellular network it's
being touted as a smart village with
fast data giving the 30 schoolchildren
that latest technology and helping to
reduce that feeling of isolation and
better security for farmers who need
military escorts when going to fields
close to the border but can now stay in
town more often and use their phones to
check and water crops the introduction
of this technology has clearly
beneficial for the people who live in
this village and obviously it's a good
marketing ploy by the company that
introduced it but undoubtedly there is
also a message in it for North Korea
which lies just beyond these fields it's
a message that says look at the
technology right on your doorstep and
consider the economic opportunities that
could come with denuclearization when
there is a peace movement around the
world I hope for an opportunity in the
future to show our technology to North
Korea but that moved towards peace
stalled after the last meeting in June
between US president Donald Trump and
North Korean leader Kim jong-un since
that meeting which was held just a few
hundred meters from Dae sung dong in the
Demilitarized Zone there have been no
further talks worrying many observers
yes I am a little bit concerned but it's
up to the North Koreans they need to
firmly commit to denuclearization
and I'm hoping that North Korea will do
so in the near future the South Koreans
say they have scrambling technology in
place so those across the border can't
access their new 5g network but as the
high-stakes diplomacy stutters high-tech
innovation is being taken as close to
North Korea as possible Wayne hey
al-jazeera in the Demilitarized Zone
South Korea